foreign
let's go to Caitlyn and where's she at
Salt Lake City what's up Caitlin how we
doing
hi Dr John how's it going good what's up
good
um
nothing much just hanging out
nothing much
yep so what's up how can I help let's
fix it yes I had a question for you so
how do my husband and I set boundaries
with our in-laws regarding
disciplining our children
oh sweet are they trying to spank your
kids or yell at your kids or something
uh yeah a little bit
oh that's so good never go back I'm just
kidding yeah it's too simple
um
oh can I just be honest with you I wish
this was a really complex answer and
it's not
you and your husband make very clear
what you will or will not tolerate when
it comes to your kids and then you give
other adults the opportunity to choose
whether they want to see their grandkids
or not it's that simple
yeah and if another adult wants to hit
my kid
then that adult does not ever get to be
in the presence of my child ever again
and that's a choice they've made not me
if another adult wants to yell at my kid
or tell racist jokes around my kid or
swear on my kid
not great good for you you will never
see my child again because that's my job
and you hear my voice like I don't give
a crap who you are you know what I mean
like I I absolutely don't care
yeah and I've had to have not oh like
those are I'm being extreme trying to
sound all tough I'm not I'm kind of a
wimp but
um I'm trying to sound tough but I've
had to have conversations with a lot of
people in my life that I love and say
hey hey
you will not talk that way in front of a
kid
yeah and
very clearly that's not gonna happen and
I've had everybody respect it but one or
two people and those people don't get to
see my kid anymore and I don't care I
don't care right yeah because they're
grown-ups and they make grown-up choices
tell your jokes do your thing I don't
care it's not gonna see my kids see see
I mean I hope you're getting my
sentiment I I it
I don't owe you anything when it comes
to my children
I agree okay so what are you
experiencing I'm talking all over you
clearly this is like a like a button for
me like what are you what are you
working through
so I guess it's not so much that we have
decided that we want to talk to our
family about how we think is appropriate
to
talk to our children like I would just
rather
to not do anything at all personally
um
but
it's hard it's really hard for my
husband to talk to his family because
they're not oh
like they're just not
the nicest or husband's poor husband I
kind of want to hug him
here's the deal I don't care and I don't
want to talk bad about your husband if
he was on the phone
I would be harder on him it's his
parents get over it suck it up tell him
yeah like you're a grown man he went and
got married and had kids that's he made
that choice
sister don't have to put your kids in
that situation if your husband's too
much of a coward to talk to his family
about how they're treating his children
then you might have to step in and say
well then my kids aren't going
yeah
does that make sense what what are they
doing
now I just know I've been talking crap
you're gonna be like well they throw
cotton balls at him when they get mad
like no what are they doing
and it's not like every time oh that's a
that's a that's abuse apologizer I don't
care if it's that every time just one
time if you hit my kid with an iron Rod
one time that's enough it doesn't have
to be every time it was just no and it's
not it's not hitting
um but like
I'm trying to think so she's she's one
she's turning two soon so she's just
barely gotten into like the throwing
tantrum phase where she freaks out you
know
um and like
he'll make almost like
not dog noises at her but like
it's a sound that you would make to
correct a dog if they were doing
something that wasn't okay right you're
getting like ah it's getting under my
skin like it's like it's like crawling
on me because I know here's it I know
exactly what it is crazy too that's that
oh my gosh you know what that is
that's that's a
that is power
yeah I have 100 million over you pet
and you know what one-year-olds do
they just get sensory overload a temper
tantrum by a one-year-old is not a
character flaw
it's not a defect they're they're one
now there's proper ways to deal it as a
parent right
and yeah hey
that is not the way to handle it
no I mean she's she's a person yeah you
know so here's the deal somebody has to
stop and say hey hey hey
you're not going to treat my child like
a dog
in that in that tone of voice
yeah I'm gonna pick up my kid
nobody's gonna whistle and here's here
is my uh
I don't know how to I don't know how to
say this without saying oh woo-woo kids
are radar systems for tension
and if they get put in the position of
somebody that thinks they're a pet
or that holds that sort of relational
hierarchy with them I am better than you
I'm superior to you I've got bigger
muscles than you here's a little lump of
human that will do whatever I say
kids feel that
and seven-year-olds don't want to go
visit granddad
yeah 13 year olds
run away from granddad
one-year-olds just light up like a
Christmas tree because that's all they
know how to do
right and so it wouldn't surprise me at
all if a kid who's had to travel to
granddad's house who's exhausted mom and
dad are tense because they're going to
in-laws house and the kids absorbing
that tension you'll show up there and
then this
yeah yeah shows up yeah that kid's gonna
have a temper tantrum you know why
that's exactly how he was made good for
him yeah he's letting you his mom know
not safe not safe not safe and then he
gets treated with a dog whistle then do
that just like straight pisses me off
and they like I'm I'm sitting here
getting fired up for you it's not even
my kid
oh trust me we both
do I just
that that is an in the moment correction
and I will pack up my stuff and go home
I just I just don't care you know what
I'm gonna have on the way home more fun
yeah right I'm gonna eat at Arby's and
Taco Bell and just get the Rockets all
the way home love my life don't care
yeah
why won't your husband talk to his
parents
too because Mom can step in and say
something too they're divorced oh okay
that's cute okay
well I wonder I wonder if I wonder if
she liked being talked to that way her
during her marriage
but
I think a lot of it is because he
was treated the same way so very
like
degraded like even as an adult like
if he does something his dad thinks is
weird or dumb or something he'll be like
why are you such an idiot you know
like he just
he just
Berets him sometimes honestly and it it
drives me crazy of course because you
love this man you know he's not an idiot
he does dumb things because he's human
but he's not an idiot and you don't want
anybody talking to your husband that way
I don't care who you are exactly
so
I think for him
like the confidence to stand up to his
dad because he knows he knows fully well
but when he does he's gonna get crap
from him that he's an idiot and he
doesn't know how to pair a kid right and
bang-up job you did Dad way to go crush
the crush the marriage too way to go Dad
you know wait knocked it knocked it out
of the park dude way to go yeah right so
when my dad tells me about parenting I
have to listen because I look at the
fruit of his three kids he did a good
job
yeah right and so even when I don't want
to hear it I do I do owe him that
respect because uh it's played out
right
um your husband doesn't have that same
luxury
it's here's the deal if he refuses or
can't or won't it's won't he can if he
won't
then at some point you say me and my
baby are not going to visit him anymore
and if he your husband wimps out and
tells his dad she don't want to come see
you anymore
she doesn't like the way you talk to the
baby
um and again I hope you can see how
cowardly that would sound but that's
probably how the conversation would go
um and he calls you you might have to
tell him
I'm tired he called my husband an idiot
because he's not he's a good man I'm
tired of you talking down to me I'm a
good wife I'm a good mom tired of you
whistling in our kid
like he's some kind of like he's a cow
out in the pasture I'm not doing it
anymore
until you treat me and my family with
dignity or respect we're out
yeah so you think it's a it's a
correction when it's happening
absolutely because that's a power
Dynamic and here's how that will
probably end because nobody stands up to
a bully like that
it will probably end with y'all packing
your crap and leaving
because I don't just based on what you
told me he ain't going back down
he's gonna stand his ground
yeah so that's what we do around here
it's hard to know because they're just
dude listen I know this guy you know why
because I grew up with this guy
I know this guy and that's why I got
such a visceral response to him dude I
moved here from West Texas like I just I
could feel it man
I can feel it
yeah it's just an arrogance that the
world bends to me
I don't care if it's a business deal I
don't care if it's a home I don't care
if it's your kid you bow before me
I don't care if it's a one-year-old that
just misses mama is tired
good grief whistling at a one-year-old
unbelievable
um I do think your husband needs to suck
it up and have a hard conversation
okay okay
um and it won't end well
and he's probably going to look at you
and say this is your fault because he
doesn't understand what relationship is
because he's never seen it
okay
yeah I mean well we're we're pretty on
the same page I mean we're
probably the complete opposite from both
of our families so good for you hey
y'all are creating something new good
for you
why do you even go why be in this dude's
presence
I don't know can I tell you what I think
it is
fantasy
this is the way these are supposed to go
the picture I had when I had a kid was
that he was going to have a great
grandparents and we're gonna have
holidays we're gonna look that look like
this we're gonna have Christmases that
look like this
and we're gonna have hunting trips and
fishing trips and shopping trips and
you're the adults in your life have
chosen that that's not going to be a
reality
and so as soon as you're able to you'll
need to create a new reality based on
the data in front of you
based on the relationships that are in
front of you
not based on how you wish it was because
wish it was isn't happening right now
and
if he's got if your father-in-law has
one iota of
reflective ability
hopefully he would ask at some point hey
why do y'all
what do you mean you're not coming for
Thanksgiving
Dad we're just gonna do it on our own
this year but I'll come down and visit
you no thank you we're going on a trip
we're gonna go to we're going to go
somewhere on our own
we're gonna start our own family
traditions
you don't like me you don't want to see
me we're tired of you calling me an
idiot I'm done with it Dad I put up with
it my whole life and I'm done with it
and I got my own son now my own daughter
now and we're not doing this again
it stops with me
that's gangster right there you know
what that is that's family tree changing
it's generational that's Legacy
that's it no more
hang on the line I'm gonna send you a
copy of on your past change your future
you and your husband can read it
together there's not a chapter on how to
have grown up hard conversations but
there is a chapter on owning reality
this is what is
and then there's a whole back half the
book on
here's what we're gonna do now
good for you for loving that kid
no more people talking your child like
they're a pet